[Music]
it's quickly becoming a thing at least
among Pittsburgh Steelers yesterday we
saw Judy Smith Schuster sign a guy's
scalp and that guy turned that autograph
into a tattoo James Conner doing the
same thing from Sharpie autograph to
actual tattoo there it is it's permanent
that is not washing off the James Conner
signature and the Steelers logo right
next to it we mentioned James Conner
because this is a big year for the
Pittsburgh Steelers we're going to play
what's more likely in this segment Chris
and the first question relates to a team
that's trying to get back to the top of
the division and the top of the
conference in Pittsburgh Steelers what's
more likely Ben Roethlisberger James
Conner and juju Smith Schuster becoming
the Steelers new version of the triplets
or the offense flops without Antonio
Brown and Le'Veon Bell well I mean I'm
gonna say it's the new I mean you give
me a choice out of those two i'm gonna
go it's a new version of the triplets i
do not think this offense is gonna flop
i just think there's still too much
talent you know offensive line one of
the best in football now it's gonna hurt
that Mike Munchak not there anymore and
that he's now with the Denver Broncos
that concerns me just as about as much
as Le'Veon Bell and Antonio Brown being
that not being there but regardless this
is a team that's had a knack as far as
finding receivers getting Donte Moncrief
and free agency drafting a few guys Oh
lines good systems good I still think
it's gonna be one of the better offenses
in all of football Mike that's the real
got to question yeah because last year
we saw what the running game could be
with James Connor and Jalen Samuels but
juju smith Schuster was number two to
Antonio Brown now Smiths Shuster is
going to be getting the attention can he
handle double teams triple teams can he
still get open and can whoever the
number two guy is whether it's Donte
Moncrief
whether it's James Washington sitting
around picked from a year ago they need
to step up Deante Johnson a guy they
drafted this year who steps up to take
advantage of the one-on-one matchups
that will be a cross from juju Smith
Schuster yeah that to me is a key also
there's a belief Vance MacDonald's going
to have a big year at tight end maybe
maybe he's somebody who takes advantage
of the extra attention paid to juju
Smith Schuster but the constant is Ben
Roethlisberger folks right you may not
like him you
you may you know you've heard the
stories and we may be you know look he's
done some things in the past that are
not good things off the field or at
least he allegedly did the bottom line
is he's a great quarterback ya can't
lose sight of the fact that he's the guy
who's still there he said recently his
arms as strong as ever and as long as he
said you know all these great receivers
gee why do they have all these great
receivers maybe it's because they have a
great quarterback who's throwing the
ball - yeah I think that's very real
Mike and I'm glad you said that about
Ben Roethlisberger because I feel like
some of the stuff that's gone on off the
field has infiltrated guy's minds and
thinking of what he is on the field and
Mike another great point by you with
Vance McDonald that that to me is the
guy that I go he might be second this
year Vance McDonald has last year kind
of entered that you know upper echelon
of tight ends and all football I'm good
in the run really good in the run game
really physical after the catch he's
kind of got some grumpiness about him
and I would bet if you made me bet money
he is the next guy in line in that
offense after juju Smith Schuster to get
a lot of balls coming his way and the
pass game but you're going with the new
triplets right you're not saying it's a
bus that you didn't answer it
no I'm saying yeah yeah no no I don't
know that you yeah I guess you
eventually answered it but I agree with
you I'd like to disagree if you see what
I agree with you I'm just not gonna say
anything yeah okay you only hear from me
when I disagree yeah Vance McDonald
assed year he basically ripped out the
soul of that Tampa Bay Buccaneers den
Civ back to you we may see more of that
this year
all right so Antonio Brown was in
Pittsburgh now he's in Oakland next
topic what's more likely for the Raiders
Antonio Brown revives Derek Carr's
career or Antonio Brown throws a temper
tantrum by week five well we could get
both I mean that's Derek Carr could be
on fire and Antonio Browns just not
happy enough he's that he's not on fire
enough that you could get both but I
think if you made me choose either one
I'm gonna say that Antonio Brown revives
Derek harsh career you know one Antonio
Brown is a phenomenal talent we know
that Nino Jon Gruden is gonna formulate
so much offense around Antonio Brown but
it's really about the rest of the
offense around Derek Carr - they've
improved the offensive line we talked
about Josh Jacobs he's going to be a
huge part of that
offense you know they signed other
receivers and free agency so the Antonio
Brown factor certainly gonna help but
it's a lot of other guys that are on
that offense that weren't there last
year that I think just make this offense
better in general let alone they're a
little desperate I mean it wasn't a good
first year and I know my man Jon Gruden
he's his butt's hot right now he wants
to you know put out a good showing in
year two and and please the fan base and
please the organization but you know I I
think that there is a good chance that
by week five we will see unless
everything works out perfectly because
this team is gonna be under a lot of
pressure as relates to their travel
schedule they get their first two games
at home they've got a Monday nighter
against the Broncos they've got the
Chiefs the following Sunday that's not
an easy start to the season though then
they go to Minnesota to Indianapolis to
England to play the Bears that's week
five that's rough if we're you know that
playing those 10:00 a.m. local time
games going to a place like Minnesota
what's gonna be a hostile environment
the great defense going to Indianapolis
where there's a great team you you could
see Derek Carr get disrupted you could
sit in and I've said this all along if
Antonio Brown does not instantly come in
and rack up the kind of numbers that he
did in Pittsburgh it's not gonna be his
fault it's not gonna be John Gruden's
fault it's gonna be Derek cars fault so
I think week five by then what we're
gonna know whether or not this thing
works
and I just I we praised Ben
Roethlisberger two minutes ago I think
we need to flip this around and say hey
what's Derek Carr done to make us think
he's gonna be as good as Ben
Roethlisberger and deliver the ball
accurately in those windows where
Antonio Brown can make those spectacular
catches I I'm gonna wait to see it
before I believe it III hear you my time
with you two I mean he's certainly not
in Ben Roethlisberger's class i we know
that and your point about the the
schedule you know that's real I mean you
know as soon as I pulled it up to I went
oh gosh I mean and then yeah it's a bye
week and then you got the go to Green
Bay in the Houston Texans so there is
definitely the possibility of danger
there if things start off slowly we know
that all right next topic what's more
likely the Ravens start the league's
newest offensive trend
or they get figured out halfway through
the season I'm gonna go when they get
figured out halfway through the season
I'm rooting for the Ravens you know I
like Greg Roman Roman and John Harbaugh
and Lamar Jackson and I love kind of
watching them bludgeon people that way
but you know I just I got us this is one
of those I got to see it to believe it
you know I've seen the Greg Roman
offense in San Francisco we saw what
they did last year with Lamar Jackson
guess things were good but as we saw
with the divisional playoff game and the
Chargers second time around team was all
over all the little wrinkles you know so
I just I got to see the passing game
work and being more efficient before I
can really buy into all of this yet and
see what Lamar Jackson looks like so I'm
gonna go they get figured out halfway
through the year you know here's the
other thing too even though the coaches
are busy getting their teams ready they
pay attention to the things that are
written and that are said and it's
almost like the Ravens are daring
defenses to come up with ways to stop
them there'd be a little cocky about an
offense they haven't even yeah yeah yeah
hey check out my new car that continues
to be in the garage I'll show it to you
in a few weeks I just think there's
there's an edge there that is going to
make other teams even more motivated to
try to pick this offense apart so given
those two choices because I really don't
think we're gonna have a new West Coast
offense coming out of Baltimore I think
it's more likely it gets figured out and
again we saw the Chargers figure out
what they were doing last year right
fairly quickly yeah definitely and again
there's just too many question marks all
together right now and as we've talked
about a lot last year it's just so hard
to just think we're gonna go on the
field and just be the more physical
dominant team week after week after week
in the NFL at some point you're gonna
meet another team that can meet meet
that physicality and then when that
happens what can you lean on in that
offense and that's what I got to see
first all right last one to San
Francisco where your buddy Kyle Shanahan
is entering his third year as the coach
what's more likely Jimmy Garoppolo stays
healthy and leads the 49ers to the
playoffs or Garoppolo stays healthy and
plays like he did early on in 2018
before he suffered that torn ACL yeah
well you know it wasn't bad before we
tore it tore that ACL but it certainly
didn't look like we saw the year before
when he came to the San Francisco 49ers
and
when six and no and everything like that
it definitely wasn't as smooth that he
missed some plays early on last year and
some passes and bad decisions definitely
but I'm going with Jimmy Garoppolo stays
healthy and leads the 49ers to the
playoffs out of these two options you
know one the desperation factor year
three for John Lynch and Kyle Shanahan
yes but I think the team has finally set
up to succeed oline really good gonna be
you know a unit there for the next few
years d line defense in general made
huge improvements last year and it's one
of the better defensive lines in all of
football and they got Nick Bosa to go
along with that and D Ford so I think
the 49ers are a playoff caliber football
team in 2019 hey I'm going off the board
Chris because the two options here where
he stays healthy ya know 49ers of the
playoffs or stays healthy and plays like
he did before he was injured I don't
think he's gonna stay out I think back
to 2016 he had a four game audition for
the rest of the NFL when Tom Brady was
suspended and he got injured in the
second game yeah and and here we at last
year and getting and it was and it
wasn't unavoidable it was his own fault
so has he smartened up will he avoid
contact what will he be able to in the
midst of all that chaos that you're in
the middle of as a quarterback have the
presence of mind to keep himself healthy
so I'm of those two options
I'm gonna go option three he doesn't
stay healthy for 16 games you're such a
pain in the butt just pick one of the
two options you know you always got to
be a diva you got to be mr. big chest
over there where you're just gonna go
off for it even if he stays healthy I
mean it's easy to and I know this is
delusion season and every team is going
to make it to the playoffs and somehow
they're all gonna win the Super Bowl
but how are they gonna make the playoffs
with the Rams and the Seahawks in their
division I know but the rest of the
conference
yeah we talked yesterday about how
loaded the NFC North is the NFC East has
to clear contenders in the Eagles and
the Cowboys the NFC South is gonna
produce one or two really good teams
it's not gonna be easy against the
playoffs so between the two options are
you gonna force me to pick one of the
two I say he stays healthy and they they
you know he plays like you did last year
and it's not I have to get to the
playoffs okay good that's all I wanted
to hear I just wanted to just we'll get
an arrow down there I want you to stay
within the rules of the segment good job
by you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports